foreign
David is on the line hi David welcome to
the Ramsay show
you all today YouTube thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
so I have a fight hustle that has turned
into something far more lucrative than I
thought I could ever be to be honest
with you that's great and it's making
yeah it's making real money
help me what's real money
I made 30 000 last year with it thirty
thousand as a side household that's good
okay
totally unexpected side hustle
um but I cannot tell you where a single
one of those thirty thousand dollars
went
um I looked at the reporting over the
weekend and I almost threw up so yeah my
my question is like how do I tame this
side hustle because it's very hand to
mouth my own personal thing no one
watches it I work and I get paid I just
want to be better with it and actually
have some money to to look at at the end
of the year what are you doing dude
so you might be able to hear in the
background but I'm actually a bird
sitter
sounded like animals yeah uh she she is
not coming down and I she will knock it
off of me but here we are
um but no I Birch that for about a
hundred different parrots in Chicago and
the number one guy on Google if you
search bird sitting Chicago I'm the
first guy that pops up so 2023 could be
a big year for me and I again just want
to make sure I'm not burning the cash as
it comes in is it just you you're the
only one bird sitting it is it is just
me yeah so I have a certification I've
worked with parrots for over half my
life and I'm very very good with them
um but yes it's just me and my me and my
Ultima driving around taking care of the
birds wow very cool good for you man
that's fun thank you so the easiest way
to get started on this is just treat it
like a business because it is
and I would just open up a separate
checking account bird sitters are us or
whatever it is right and just uh put
your name on there uh David so and so
DBA doing business as uh bird Setters R
Us and you just do it your social
security number you don't even need a
tax ID number to do it and then throw
all of your bird sitting money into that
account
and then you can just pull up the
register on that account at any point
and you can tell what's going on you can
tell where the money is right and then
if you pull it out of there to bring it
home
quote unquote out of the business you
need to set aside a fourth of it for
taxes because as you have discovered you
have seven thousand five hundred dollars
in taxes due on this don't you sure do
yep and don't have any money
well that I was smart enough to do to
like have it move
um the processor that I use will save
the taxes for you so I have that set
aside at least so I'm not like facing
down Uncle Sam with a brown face good
good um but I do have another kind of
follow-up question how do you find the
discipline because I I did that I made a
threat protecting account and I'm like
oh I'm not going to look at the money
and then I'm like oh this thing this
thing this thing it just it just goes my
mom says I'm like a sieve with cash wait
a minute it goes out of the it goes out
of the bird account
yeah I just spend it like what are some
tips for discipline on that like okay
you don't have a budget on your personal
account do you
I don't have a budget on anything yeah I
know I could tell it sounds like he
needs to sit down and and keep his money
separate you've got your personal money
on one side you've got your business
money on a separate side and uh David it
sounds like with your business you
really need to get organized and write
down what your outgo is what your
expenses are right and and and how much
money that you're bringing in to find
out if you really can't you know and and
decide can I take a payroll if I can
it's going to be this amount and I'm
going to do it you know every month and
really just get organized it sounds like
that's really what you're lacking
because the business sounds like it's
making money it almost sounds like it's
making so much money for you that you
feel like you can be frivolous and I
think that that's a dangerous place to
be lazy um what's the uh what's your day
job pay
so no I make 70k a year okay so you have
a hundred thousand dollars coming in how
old are you
33 and you're broke
yes okay here's your why
you need to get disgusted with how
stupid that is
yes it is so stupid I know I mean that's
a good thing I mean it's like after
covet I ate so many donuts that I got
disgusted about how fat I got
so because I ate every donut in a 50
mile so you have to get disgusted and go
I'm going to change this crap this is
crazy and I you know you got to have a
there's a healthy level of disgust that
precedes human transformation
like I've had it I'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired I don't like this
feeling of being this inept I don't like
this taste of regret with a hundred
grand going through my fingers and I
have no idea where it goes that taste on
my tongue is awful it's like a bad
fruitcake this time of year right and so
I want to stop that so now now we've got
and you called here and so you already
knew right you are you knew that you
told me what I just told you back I
didn't tell you anything new I'm not you
called him stupid no I just said what
are you doing stupid okay so no you know
but so here's the thing now you gotta
now you gotta why because if you keep
eating like you've been eating You're
Gonna Keep looking like you've been
looking you keep spinning like you've
been spinning you're gonna keep being
broke like you've been broke you got to
change your habits so we're going to sit
down and do a personal budget on where
the money's gonna go and then when we
move money out of the bird account into
the personal account minus tax
withholding then and we've got an
assignment for it already preset in the
personal budget but the personal budget
is just regret avoidance it's just
Financial hangover avoidance
like I drank too much and I feel like
crap for three days right it's the same
thing you got this tape you got this
hangover and it's the exact same thing
you've been partying and and you're
tired of it it's time you just said I'm
gonna grow up good for you well done
we're going to help you hang on send you
a copy of the book The Total Money
Makeover which will walk you through
exactly what to do but you just need to
say I'm worth fixing this because I
don't like where I am so I'm going to
change it